hi my name is Karen Garcia I'm a carnal
developer after a Wolfram research and
my talk will be on a urine vr using the
Wolfram language where I will briefly
talk about how you can use Mathematica
and unity link to create air and
applications my name is Karen I'm a
kernel developer in the discrete
computation team in algorithms
department and I'm gonna talk to you
guys today about augmented reality and
virtual reality in the Wolfram language
so for virtual reality in the Wolfram
language with the release of version 12
we have unity link which allows the
Wolfram language to work seamlessly to
create to create unity components and
game objects that you can then use to
create virtual reality applications
across many different platforms
and so unity provides the users with the
ability to create these VR applications
and I'm going to show you a video of one
that we had made previously
so this gallery was created in unity
using a Unity link and as you can see
you can walk around in virtual space and
a lot of these game objects that you see
here were actually created through
Mathematica and then placed into a Unity
game scene but since I have limited time
I'm going to move on to the main purpose
of this talk I'm going to focus more on
augmented reality so as unity provides
support for VR it also provides support
for augmented reality and I'm actually
going to walk us through a demo to
building an application so in this one
you will be able to create an augmented
reality scale so you can scale different
objects as well as rotate them in a
virtual space and I'm gonna talk a
little bit about the requirements that
you that you need to go through so
for the someone we're gonna be building
to this iPad and to build an iOS you
need it is recommended that you have an
Apple Developer account or at least an
Apple ID so that you can build in Xcode
you also need the latest version of
Xcode which you can get at that website
you also need unity 2019 point 1.3 or
newer and then a series of different
packages that I'll go through as well
obviously a compatible iOS device with
iOS 12 or newer and the most important
part so that you can actually build to
iOS is making sure that you set I Oh SSD
build for the platform settings so that
you can actually build to it so some
other things that you need for AR is to
make sure that you have this camera
description so that the user so that the
Xcode knows that you're actually using
the camera for something okay so to
begin the link with Mathematica you need
to evaluate Unity link and then you can
open a project which this one I've
already created and then this will open
unity in a separate window and once it
does that we can whoops
alright so here's one that I had
previously built but I'm going to go
through this process again so that you
can see how this whole process what so
once you do that you can create an asset
directory which is usually how people
that develop in unity organize their
their content for their games so I'm not
gonna evaluate this one because I
already did this one but we're gonna
create a new unity scene so in this case
we're gonna call it a or scale and as
you can see here it's created here and
then in case you didn't believe me it's
right here so you can set up the scene
and for for augmented reality you need
to make sure that you have an error
session and an error session origin
because this is what it's what's
to tell unity that hey this there's an
AR scene and we're gonna place it here
there's gonna be an AR camera here and
this is already set so this comes with
one of the packages so in this case I'm
using AR kit that is the app Apple's
augmented reality kit and so it creates
the game objects as you can see okay so
then we're gonna create this err session
so then you will see them here and this
is really tiny but there's an air camera
there so then in the case of this
application I'm gonna put a canvas which
is where the sliders that you saw in the
previous scene we're at so the sliders
are gonna have the words rotation and
also scale so that's where you can
rotate the actual objects that you're
gonna put in the scene and also make
them bigger or smaller so as with every
unity scene you need light so that's one
I'm gonna add and I'm deleting the main
camera because there's an air camera so
you can't have two cameras in the scene
so we don't care about the main camera
we just want the AR one so then I'm
going to create this space where I'm
going to put the content so that's where
I'm gonna put the geometrical objects
that are gonna appear in my application
then you can also manipulate the
position as well as the rotation and the
scale of these objects so in this case
I'm gonna change the position of my lady
and my content so now there are some
scripts that need to go in this so that
the objects know that when you change
the scale you need to make them bigger
or smaller or that you're rotating them
and these are scripts that are that I've
already put in there so we're just gonna
find them and we're gonna put them where
they need to be so now I'm gonna do the
fun part which is creating the actual
objects that you're going to see in
augmented reality so in this case I'm
going to make a spiky and I'm gonna make
a revolution plot so that you can see it
and walk around with it
so once I do that they're not gonna have
any color so as you can see here's the
scale and the rotation they're not gonna
have any color and that's kind of boring
so I'm gonna add some random colors to
it oh whoops sorry evaluated this too
early so I'm gonna add some color to it
and then I'm gonna make them and then
I'm gonna make them go into that content
hierarchy that I already built so that
it knows that it needs to be in this
position and then I'm going to change
the position slightly so that we can see
both objects in the same scene and then
I'm going to add capsule Collider so
that we can we won't actually bump into
them in augmented reality right so once
I do that let me see if I can show you
this once you do that the entire scene
is built and then we can just save the
unity scene and we can build it so once
you do that you're gonna get an Xcode
project and again this is just for iOS
other platforms have different build
settings so once you get that you're
going to get this Xcode project file and
you click it which opens it in the
latest Xcode version and once you choose
the correct device that you're building
to in this case the iPad and this case
this iPad you're then gonna click Play
which will then take you to the screen
and make sure that you pick yourself so
in this case I picked myself as the
developer for this and once you do that
it will build the application here which
I'm going to show you
give me a second
listen so you can all see yourselves and
then here are the sliders that I would
that I built right so this one is the
rotation and then this one is the scale
so these are the two objects that I made
the spiky and the revolution plot now in
the case of this application there's
also a plane detector so that's all the
white spaces that you see this is the
camera actively looking for planes where
you can place the object so if I want to
switch here I can switch right here or I
can switch it here and I can rotate the
objects as well as makeable sorry as
well make them bigger or smaller right
and I can go around the room and it'll
detect different planes so in this case
they are here and then there will be
more planes sometimes it takes a while
for them to detect because there's like
a bunch of different things that it has
to take into account but you can move
them around again you can rotate them
and you can make them bigger or smaller
and so this is how you can use the
Wolfram language to create different so
the models that you can create with
Mathematica can then go into something
like augmented reality or virtual
reality which we actually have demos of
downstairs
yep any questions concerns nope so there
yeah so the question was about the
planes so these planes are detected by a
plane manager that was included in the
AR kit package that iOS provides so that
is how those are being tracked yes
so it's just making sure that the
objects are not so okay let me see if I
can so that I won't bump into them when
I move yes and so that you can if I had
a longer cable I would be able to walk
around the object itself and see it what
do you write so so the thing is a unity
link provides you a way so that you
don't have to do a lot of the processes
through unity you can control them
through Mathematica using unity link
yeah so you can create game objects you
can change the lighting you can even
access some of the other menus mm-hmm
holes in the spiky shadows oh oh right I
see well that probably has to do with
the inputs of the model you're talking
about these right hold on these right
here right yeah yeah yeah yeah I think
it just has to do with the baking of the
scene because there so this this one
that I'm working that I'm running right
now is just the development belt so it's
not even fully baked yes
so unity provides you the ability to
built a different platform so you can
build to like Xbox Android and
everything it's just the packages that
you pick need to be slightly different
so for iOS you need the AR kit which is
not compatible with Android so you would
just need the AR core and I think
cardboard as well yeah so this is extra
so the final application is built so
what unity gives you is an Xcode project
and that project is then built through
Xcode so there's a lot of background
stuff that Xcode does in order to build
the final project I'm not sure if I
answered your question so this this is
just reading your camera these spaces
are then you you place these objects on
the planes that are being tracked
through the camera no so this is
actually through unity the plane the
plane detector is actually something
that you put in unity through the kit
that they give you mm-hmm I think
somebody else had a question yes
so you can run if you use unity link you
can use Mathematica code to go back and
forth so in this moment this is the
build so this was so that you guys could
see it live but if you were in the unity
editor you could still make changes
using Mathematica